spoiler warning obviously star wars the
force awakens was probably the most
anticipated movie of all time in fact
the word anticipated doesn't describe it
properly
a more accurate description would be
basically this movie was being hyped as
a transcendent experience a movie that
could bring world peace and hunger and
malnutrition and be perfect with not a
single flaw or complaint because heaven
forbid a Star Wars movie be just good a
lot of this is due to expectations and
speculation something I personally feel
is damaging to the movie-going
experience my goal with this analysis is
to discuss not just the events of the
film by likes and dislikes and cool
tidbits but also talk about the effect
Star Wars has on people myself others
and what that can mean so let's get
started I loved this movie what what
yeah it was my favorite movie of 2015
what you lost it was almost inevitable
that a film being praised as the second
coming before it was even seen by anyone
would likely disappoint people when you
build something up in your mind and mull
over it coming up with theories and
desires of what you'd personally like to
see it's easy to be let down by
everything that doesn't meet those
expectations upon my first viewing I
left disappointed that I didn't get more
Luke Skywalker I sat in my car having
loved the experience but annoyed that
Luke was in the film for one minute I
could already see the internet comments
oMG Luke was in the movie for five
seconds and didn't say anything worst
movie ever
it wasn't until I sat down and began to
take notes from my review that I
realized I had the completely wrong
viewpoint why was I disappointed in the
lack of Luke did JJ Abrams ever say that
Luke had a significant role in the film
was Luke ever notably included in any of
the trailers or marketing no he wasn't
in fact Mark Hamill didn't even do
interviews or any press tours I was
saddened by a lack of Luke because I had
built an expectation in my brain of what
I personally wanted to see without
realizing that Lawrence Kasdan and JJ
Abrams weren't telling that story at all
I came to the conclusion that what
abrams had done was actually admirably
brave especially as such a huge fan of
Star Wars
think about it this is a guy who grew up
playing with action figures of Luke
Skywalker and now he has a chance to
direct a movie with him and what does he
do
tell a new story with new characters hey
Chris you said a new story it's not a
new story it's the same retread of yeah
yeah we'll get to that
don't worry where was I oh yeah he made
a movie with new compelling characters
as a monumental Star Wars fan his choice
to limit Luke's appearance was very wise
and surprisingly restrained in the end I
really respected him for it
now please keep in mind that I'm not
suggesting that our expectations being
subverted is always a positive thing I
had all kinds of ideas for Indiana Jones
in the Kingdom of the colossal
disappointment and they were all better
than what we actually got I'm just
highlighting that unrealistic
expectations can be harmful and
unhealthy for a movie going experience
when this picture of Luke leaked onto
the net thousands of websites published
it hoping to make a ton of ad revenue
ruining the discovery and surprise I
wonder if after seeing the movie and
realizing Luke was only involved for one
minute if any of these websites felt
they had made a mistake I can only hope
because they did anyway let's switch it
up a little bit for this review normally
I talk about the pros first things I
liked about the movie and I discuss what
I didn't like the cons last but since
some very thoughtful people out there
have kindly suggested that I was
oblivious to the force awakens
containing any flaws your fanboy piece
of shit all you like is Captain America
and lightsabers - asshole face it's such
a nice treat for me being cranky I
thought I'd discuss what I didn't like
about the force awakens first here we go
the CGI wrath tars they're never shown
in close-up but they just look
artificial to me
I like the sequence but not there look
they reminded me of that men in black
slug that was eating the back of the
Train Maz Kanata she kind of looks like
a dried-up apricot she reminds me of the
prequels ooh
Snoke he confused me was he a giant
stirrer just a hologram being projected
giant I'm thinking he was just being
projected giant also the CGI for him is
inexcusably mediocre this is the big one
for me
Return of the Jedi having a second Death
Star pushed it Starkiller base was
basically a third one
it felt shoehorned in as a big weapon
for the resistance to battle I didn't
care when it blew up the planets and I
didn't care when the base exploded it
was unnecessary pose rapid explanation
for his disappearance
it was lazy writing that felt thrown in
at the last minute to accommodate Poe's
return to the screenplay because Abrams
has confirmed he was originally killed
off in the beginning r2 coming to life
to provide the map to Luke felt
convenient to me
although upon further thought it seems
there is most definitely a logical
explanation involving Rey's presence
bb-8 saying the right thing and Luke
possibly releasing a hold he had placed
on r2 the two times that a character
acknowledges familial ties felt
overdramatic with pauses and inflections
that actually seemed like they were
telling the audience and lastly John
Williams score disappointed me race
theme was the only memorable new piece
and most of the action cues felt kind of
phoned in this could be due to a health
issue he faced last year bridge of spies
was the first Spielberg movie in decades
he was unable to compose for and I felt
his soundtrack may have been rushed and
that's about it
I basically loved everything else the
force awakens reminded me why I love
movies it reached out of the screen
grabbed my shoulder shook me and said
hey movies are awesome aren't they by
far the major complaint thrown at the
force awakens is that it borrowed too
much from a new hope because the seventh
film in a franchise that started in the
1970s that followed a similar formula as
the first couldn't possibly be any good
right oh I guess it could is this fair
criticism if so many people seem to
think it is then it must be right well
that is the day and age we live in
thumbs up on a comment or the amount of
shares and article gets or the Rotten
Tomatoes consensus seems to decide that
in a
in his right or wrong when I was a kid a
popular saying was of course it's true I
saw it on TV now it's evolved into of
course I'm right
look how many other people agree with me
nearly every single franchise in
existence has a formula and most sequels
within a franchise follow a similar
formula simply changing a few elements
to help differentiate it from its
predecessors a prime example of this
would be the Indiana Jones franchise if
you've been watching my videos for some
time you know that the original Indiana
Jones trilogy is one of my favorite
things on planet Earth they inspired me
heavily as a kid and even more so as an
adult but let's be honest they're all
the same movies Indiana Jones
starts his adventure by obtaining
something valuable then eventually
losing it in Raiders it's the idol in
Temple it's the remains of nurhachi in
crusade it's the cross of Coronado
kingdom of who gives a shit actually
changed this formula up by introducing
the main villain the supporting villain
and the aliens in its opening scene then
he meets a woman whether it's Marion
Willy
or Elsa again Kingdom changed this by
saving Marion for later then they're
somehow informed of a new MacGuffin and
must search for it
Raiders had the Ark Temple had the
Shankara stones crusade had the Holy
Grail and kingdom has the skull there's
always a scene with some kind of creepy
crawly whether it's snakes bugs rats or
ants eventually the woman becomes a
damsel in distress Marion gets captured
so does Willy so does Elsa and in
Kingdom Marion was already captured from
the start there's always a bare-knuckle
fistfight with the supporting villain
Raiders has the airplane fight temple
has the conveyor belt fight crusade has
the tank fight
Kingdom has the big Russian dude there
is always a scene where Indy gets his
ass kicked to near death before finally
coming out on top and Raiders he gets
shot pummeled and dragged behind a truck
then he punches the Nazi real hard in
Temple he gets whipped beaten and
voodooed then he punches the thug II
real heart in crusade he gets dragged by
a tank
and hit with a shovel then he punches
Vogel real hard in Kingdom well Indies
pretty much on top of things the entire
time and this vulnerability is an on
display there's always a big chase scene
to start the third act the truck chase
the mine car chase the tank chased the
jungle chase and once the MacGuffin is
found it always kills the bad guy now
lock opens the arc
bholaraam falls to his death trying to
catch the stones Donovan drinks from the
Grail spout Co wants too much fuckin
knowledge see they're all the same movie
but did you notice something the only
film in the franchise that attempted to
change the formula in a few ways is
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull and it's by
far the worst one huh
many disliked Indiana Jones for myself
included but were unable to explain
exactly why in truth it messed with a
successful formula too much it didn't
feel like an Indiana Jones movie because
it actually did try to do something
different every once in a while it just
didn't do it well like three other
movies that we'll talk about soon and
don't worry I'll bring all of this
Indiana Jones talked back to Star Wars
very soon but first let's go back to
1989 Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
had just come out an initial review
stated that the film was essentially a
copy of Raiders of the Lost Ark many
viewed Temple of Doom as too dark and
violent and while it followed the same
basic formula of Raiders aesthetically
it was a very different film we'll talk
more about how aesthetics can be
misleading later two of my favorite
critics of all time the late great Gene
Siskel and Roger Ebert had this to say
about the Last Crusade one thing I will
agree with you though is that the plots
are very similar between this one in the
first one remember in the first one the
Nazis were after the Ark of the Covenant
this time they're after the Holy Grail
and I get tired at all whether they were
just going through the story didn't you
think see I've been through this before
a little loud no no I didn't I tell you
what you've got to realize this is the
third in the series maybe spielberg is
wise to end
at this point because we are now
familiar essentially with what we can
expect strange locations
unbelievable adventurers next arrest
snakes and rats and so forth I like to
look at Venice and the look of those
category your reaction noted the first
one where she first one was absolutely
smashing it was a great film but it was
also a new film a new car was a new it
was a new film in the sense that I
hadn't seen that energy level before
right I hadn't seen that technical level
before I hadn't seen Harrison Ford in
that role before and I felt actually
that's filled working with this one I
think it's a very good film well I felt
like I had seen it before this is the
type of instant gut reaction that the
force awakens is currently receiving by
some naysayers we've seen it before it's
the same as the original years later The
Last Crusade is actually considered by
some to be the best film in the
franchise having the visceral action of
Raiders along with an undercurrent of
dramatic heft with Indy and his father
that Raiders simply didn't have but upon
its initial release Crusade was chided
as a tired retread of the original so
let's talk a bit about Star Wars formula
we're now seven movies deep into the
Star Wars franchise and at this point
the formula is obvious opening crawl pan
down to space every film doesn't if
force awakens didn't do this a mob would
have formed outside JJ Abrams house the
opening scene always demonstrates the
power of the main villain in the movie
new hope shows the massive Star
Destroyer Empire has the Star Destroyer
sending out probes return has Darth
inspecting the new Death Star Phantom
Menace has the Jedi encountering the
Trade Federation clones has the queen's
decoy blowing up revenge has Palpatine
being rescued from the evil Count Dooku
and the force awakens shows the first
order and kylo slaughter a village a
potential hero is discovered somewhere
generally he or she is of a lowly
profession who dreams of adventure Luke
was a moisture farmer who wanted to join
the rebellion
you know the rebellion against the
Empire Anakin was a slave who hoped to
grow up strong and liberate his family
and friends and
dreama's a Jedi I came back here freed
all the slaves Rey was a scavenger who
collected rebel artifacts and dreams
that the stories of old are actually
true this is a minute in Vulcan our hero
then meets someone older who teaches
them something important about the force
or life in general
Luke meets obi-wan Kenobi Luke meets
Yoda Luke goes to Yoda again Anakin
meets qui-gon and it can trains under
obi one and it can trains under
Palpatine Rey meets Han Rey meets Luke
there's always an entertaining badass a
new hope had Han the prequels had Darth
Maul I guess the force awakens has Finn
and Poe there's a cute side character
the originals had r2d2 the prequels
tried to have Jar Jar and the force
awakens had bb-8 there's always a
familial connection
the originals add Vader and Luke as
father and son and the prequels told the
origins of that story and Anakin and
obi-wan were supposed to be like
brothers I guess my brother Anakin
I love the force awakens has kylo Ren as
the son of Han and Leia and the
grandchild of Darth Vader someone
important generally dies and usually
they're the older wise character
a new hope killed off obi-wan Phantom
Menace killed off qui-gon force awakens
killed off Han there's always a cloaked
in black villain a new hope and Empire
had Darth Vader returned introduced the
Emperor Phantom Menace had Darth Maul
clones had Count Dooku and revenge had
the Emperor again Force awakens has kylo
Ren there's usually a space battle with
a big ship or weapon the Death Star the
Death Star Trade Federation
Starkiller base there's always a
lightsaber battle Darth versus obi-wan
Luke vs. Vader Luke vs. Vader qui-gon
and obi-wan versus Darth Maul obi-wan
and Anakin versus Count Dooku
obi-wan versus Anakin ray versus kylo
except for the Empire Strikes Back every
single previous Star Wars film ends with
complete finality and barely a single
reason to watch the next one a new hope
ends with an awards ceremony
return ends with our heroes celebrating
Phantom Menace ends with our heroes
celebrating clones ends with a marriage
celebration and revenge ends with baby
Luke and a sunset so what's the point
I'm getting at here the point is that
force awakens is not the first Star Wars
movie to follow a formula we've seen
before every single Star Wars movie has
a checklist with each box firmly checked
off it's just that some do this much
better than others I think the reason
force awakens is being targeted as a
copy is aesthetics the way the film
looks its visual construct people tend
to be very critical of what they see
because that's the easiest aspect to
zero in on watching force awakens it
visually looks and feels like the
original Star Wars trilogy and that was
the point I read a comment that said the
prequels sucked but I at least respect
George for trying to do something
different as we've just discussed the
formula and overall themes of the
prequels were basically the exact same
as the original trilogy what was so
different about the prequels was the
and feel many people have said that the
prequels simply didn't feel like Star
Wars and that's because they didn't but
if you actually look at the prequel
screen place the events that take place
and the beats of the writing they really
are the same story just with a few
characters and elements shifted around
and I don't have a problem with that
because I recognize that's how
franchises generally work if you're
still not quite catching my drift I have
a short presentation I'd like to share
with you this next segment was provided
by accomplished editor Pablo Fernandez
who has given me permission to use this
clip he cut together the link for his
original upload is in the description
below
please enjoy this you see the echo of
where it all is going to go it's like
poetry so if they run
so I think it's pretty clear at this
point the Star Wars movies all echo one
another George Lucas himself described
them like poetry with each stanza
rhyming I have no idea why people aren't
making this connection the issue that
force awakens faces is that admittedly
perhaps too often it throws in visual
nods to the originals like Finn finding
the remote that Luke trained with or
accidentally turning on the game board
or a cantina scene or putting something
secret in a droid there's also a desert
planet that resembles Tatooine a snow
planet that resembles ha and a forest
planet that resembles Endor so not only
does the force awakens' have standard
Star Wars themes it also had visual
callbacks as I've already stated it's a
lot simpler to pratik what we see and
harder to think about what we're seeing
yes the force awakens absolutely pays
homage to the originals while also
sticking close to a formula and that's
why people said it feels so much like a
new hope which was clearly the point
from the start not everyone but the vast
majority were disappointed in the
prequels because they simply didn't feel
like Star Wars now that we have a movie
that feels like Star Wars it apparently
feels a little too much like Star Wars
basically at this point I'm not sure
it's even possible to please Star Wars
fans anymore so what I'm going to say
next might strike some as surprising
because the entire internet seems to
think that it's simply a fact that the
force awakens copies the Star Wars
formula without doing anything new I
actually feel that in some ways force
awakens changes the formula up how you
say let's discuss in a new hope Luke
Skywalker meet obi-wan Kenobi and after
his family is killed he decides that he
wants to learn the ways of the force
obi-wan takes him under his wing and
Luke is quickly taught about the force
and learns to harness it faster than
obi-wan perhaps even expected however in
the force awakens rey is already
completely self-sufficient on jakku she
takes care of herself she makes her own
money and eventually she discovers that
she's force sensitive on her own without
anyone's help in
digs deep within her to allow some of
this to come out let's discuss Darth
Vader one of the most badass villains of
all time but let's focus on his
character in a new hope imagine that
it's 1977 and you just saw Star Wars you
just saw Darth Vader for the first time
what might your initial thoughts have
been Wow Darth Vader looked so cool and
he was so cool when he choked that guy
and he was so cool with his lightsaber
man he was so cool I don't mean to
diminish one of the greatest movie
characters of all time but it wasn't
really until the Empire Strikes Back
that we learned anything about Darth
Vader as a person a new hope does hint
at a passed between Kenobi and Vader in
one scene but for the most part he's
just a badass villain dressed in black
now let's talk about the villain of
force awakens kylo Ren what do we know
about him from just one movie he's the
son of Han Solo he's conflicted he can
feel a pull toward good he idolizes
Darth Vader and views him as a martyr
and he's fearful that he won't live up
to his idol he was the catalyst that
ripped Luke Leia and Han apart he's
young inexperienced and his training
isn't complete even his lightsaber
reflects this it's obvious that a novice
without full training constructed it the
core looks unstable and it's really a
mirror image of his unhinged personality
so in many ways the force awakens has
crafted a far more compelling villain
than a new hope did in its first outing
it's criminally unfair to say that kylo
doesn't live up to Vader because we've
had six movies and endless expanded
universe novels and games to flesh out
Vader my point is if you just take the
first movies in both trilogies one of
them clearly did a better job at
presenting a humanized person motivated
by deep personal feelings
the force awakens also humanized another
classic Star Wars element a stormtrooper
this is the first time we've ever
really seen underneath the mask of one
of these guys we saw a trooper die in
front of him wiping blood across his
helmet and in just that one visual image
stormtroopers were suddenly people I
loved the first order genuinely felt
like a real operating team with both the
riot trooper and kylo calling Finn a
traitor
Finn's backstory is intriguing and I
can't wait to learn more about him let's
talk about Han Solo in the originals he
was a scoundrel a smuggler he was cocky
self-assured and just plain awesome but
he wasn't buying any of that for scrap
hokey religions and ancient weapons are
no match for a good blaster at your side
kid you don't believe in the force do
you the force awakens' gave us the
chance to see an older wiser Han Solo
someone who when asked about the force
says it's true
he's grown he's matured let's not forget
about the most important new aspect of
his character he's a father when he sees
kylo on the battlefield I nearly lost it
at the sight of this beloved
scruffy-looking nerf-herder suddenly
brought down to earth han hasn't been
this interesting since he said no also
this movie displayed dark and exciting
new uses of the force with kylo Ren
traversing the thoughts of his prisoners
he referred to as guests and stopping
laser beams in midair and please don't
tell me something like this happened in
the books here's my collection of Star
Wars books have I read them all no but I
know my shit about Star Wars ok ok the
movie also had a wonderfully diverse
cast with guys girls blacks whites
Asians and Akbar's getting equal
treatment it really was awesome to see
and then there's the ending which we've
already discussed briefly aside from
Empire every Star Wars movie previously
ends with a tightly wrapped bow and a
feeling of warm comforting closure the
Empire Strikes Back
and the force awakens smartly ended
their films with a cliffhanger keeping
the story interesting even after the
credits have finished playing and we're
driving home from the theater does the
force awakens follow a familiar formula
yes it most certainly does but as I've
already explained virtually all of the
Star Wars movies do I was pleased to see
the force awakens breathe new life into
its characters and take them in
surprising new directions and that's
something I must stress characters this
movie had fantastic characters the fact
that I watched a Star Wars movie
featuring Han Leia and Luke yet found
myself more invested in rey finn poe and
bb-8 is a major accomplishment it's also
important to keep in mind the position
abrams and Kaz dad were in Disney had
just bought Lucasfilm for four billion
dollars really think about that four
billion dollars the prequels had turned
many Star Wars fans away from that
beloved galaxy this was not the time to
write a script that took place entirely
in the Masai
the cantina with Han Solo and Luke
Skywalker just chatting for two hours so
they did play it safe and for this
reintroduction to the Star Wars universe
I was more than fine with that
and I feel that it was probably the wise
choice with this review I want to
discuss something that I fear is slowly
but surely being ignored by many film
reviews today filmmaking I can't tell
you how many reviews I've read over the
past few years that all but entirely
avoid mentioning things like camerawork
lighting editing or the like let's
discuss the filmmaking on display in the
force awakens and why I think it's the
best directed film in the saga since the
Empire Strikes Back
something that Abrams does very well is
keep the camera rolling where many
directors would feel the need to cut
Abrams combines what may have been five
different setups for your average film
into one he's clearly very inspired by
Spielberg in this regard Abrams once
again does us with the force awakens and
not only is it a great time-saver as
less setups take less time but it also
showcases the brilliant art direction as
multiple viewings will bring out things
in the background that really make the
location seem real something else Abrams
did remarkably well was never let the
action or amazing imagery outshine the
characters take this shot for instance
behind our heroes the first-order
approaches explosions are right on their
tail but never do we cut away to those
explosions behind them to go ah look at
the x-games abrams always keeps our
heroes in the foreground and the focus
is entirely on their dialogue while also
keeping the frame wide enough to
showcase how fast they're running in one
shot we feel the intensity of the action
recognize the looming danger behind them
but don't lose our focus on the most
important part the characters Abrams
with this film in particular has proven
himself a master at scene transitions
nearly every scene in the force awakens
starts with something eye-catching ray
opens the compartment really fast
Finn wakes up startled you get the point
this keeps the film moving fast it's
also the funniest film in the saga
by far BBA giving the thumbs up with the
lighter Han preferring Chuy's bow caster
Chui oblivious at Han being referred to
as a war hero Rae popping in and out of
the Millennium Falcon's compartment the
stormtroopers turning away during kylos
rage the humor was so fast and so well
realized it was such a pleasure to watch
a funny Star Wars film again something
else I loved was that many of the
characters often appear to have a sense
of awe when seeing amazing things this
was something the prequels lacked people
walked around these incredible
environments but never seemed amazed by
their surroundings when Poe is being
escorted out of the ship in the
beginning of the film he stops to look
around in awe
stuff like this is great it makes our
heroes feel like they're in a real place
and it reminds us as viewers that we
should be amazed by the world - let's
talk about something more subtle the
lighting what we're gonna focus in on
one scene the death of Han Solo yeah
that one
throughout Hans approach to his son
kylos face is lit partially in red and
partially in bluish white this helped
highlight the conflict going on within
him it was similar to the scene in
Return of the Jedi when Luke faced a
moment of temptation but then all the
light leaves the room and kylo space is
drenched in red the dark side has
triumphed and he murders his father this
is fantastic
subtle work this is honestly something
I'm deeply worried about when it comes
to film criticism people for whatever
reason have begun to drift away from
discussing filmmaking are they afraid to
bore their readers or viewers I don't
know but it's a frightening development
as of late and it's something I'm trying
to avoid here on my channel now
something I feel I must stress is that
if you didn't like this movie that's
more than fine I'm consistently baffled
by the inability to accept different
opinions on the internet I mean last
year someone actually said to my face
that Anakin Skywalker in the Phantom
Menace was his favorite Star Wars
character of all time because he's just
so cute my point is with this video and
really my whole channel my goal isn't to
say I'm right
are wrong this is just an outlet I can
use to explain myself my thoughts and
what I saw in the force awakens while
watching it because trust me I've
already been taken aback my articles
written by supposed professionals that
come off as highly elitist a feeling
Gene Siskel described as aloof hovering
over the audience not having a communal
experience with everyone else I mean
look at this title admit it the force
awakens stinks they should have just
retitled that hey I like you're wrong
can I ask please all things are proven
with time upon the initial release of
the Phantom Menace many fans were more
than satisfied with the experience all
those better than her the Jedi
personally so did a good job I like the
special effects I thought Lucas did a
really good job I think the little attic
and Skywalker and everyone's gonna say
it stole that movie thumbs up or thumbs
up um god I put my feet up if I could as
time has gone on that feeling of
euphoria has gone away and the truth has
set in Phantom Menace was a poorly acted
awkwardly written mess there were no
entertaining characters and the action
felt weightless that excitement and
denial I refer to as phantom menacing
may have been present in some with the
force awakens but not myself there were
multiple aspects of this film I
mentioned earlier that I felt could have
been improved on significantly and in
some cases completely removed like
Starkiller base but that's not to say
that the force awakens isn't obviously a
very well acted movie with very good
dialogue which is something that the
Phantom Menace most definitely did not
have you'll never reach the outskirts of
time sandstorms are very very dangerous
on the flip side I have a first-hand
account from both of my parents that
upon leaving the theater in 1980 having
just seen the Empire Strikes Back for
the first time many people including my
parents were very disappointed it ended
on a sad note with a cliffhanger and
many people at that time considered it a
massive disappointment The Empire
Strikes Back is the lowest grossing film
of the franchise for this reason it
didn't encourage the returns that a new
hope had it has only been with the
passage
time that the Empire Strikes Back has
become well respected is not just a
great Star Wars movie but a great film
in fact even the critics in 1980 were
very mixed on it to prove this point
here's a quote from the original review
from Variety The Empire Strikes Back is
a worthy sequel to Star Wars equal in
both technical mastery and
characterization suffering only from the
familiarity with the effects generated
in the original and imitated too much by
others at 124 minutes Empire is only
three minutes longer than its
predecessor but seems to be longer than
that probably because of the over
familiarity with some of the space
sequences and excessive saber duels
between Vader and Hamill here's another
quote from the original review from
People magazine this movie of course is
star wars 2 and while it's hardly the
worst sequel ever made Exorcist 2
retired that trophy it's not up to the
original either the spacecraft laser
battle gimmicks are familiar now so even
though these are the most special love
the special effects they're no longer
fascinating worse the more one sees the
main characters the less appealing they
become the ending is emotionally
unsatisfying though that's no accident
Lucas says this is only the first of
eight sequels which ought to be enough
to wear out the batteries and Luke's
light sword and The Wall Street Journal
had this to say back in 1980 and well
one can I suppose blame an absence of
freshness for its lack of power this too
hardly seems crucial after all it's
precisely because they want more of the
same that many viewers will come to
Empire in the first place greeting the
appearance of all their old friends with
delight and the New York Times review
had this to say Empire Strikes Back is
not a truly terrible movie it's a nice
movie it's not by any means as nice as
Star Wars it's not as fresh and funny
and surprising and witty but it is nice
and inoffensive and in a way that no one
associated with it need be ashamed of
it's also silly I mean was this really
the pinnacle of journalism in 1980 the
New York Times raves it's a nice movie
did you happen to notice a parallel
that ran through every one of those
initial reviews every single one stated
that the Empire Strikes Back felt
familiar like a retread it wasn't fresh
anymore it lacked originality rather
than actually discussing the film these
reviewers compared it to what they'd
already seen and almost came off as
wanting to dislike it so basically Star
Wars movies have been accused of copying
off of one another for decades it's the
same tired gripe people have had since
1980 once you've seen Star Wars you can
never see Star Wars again for the first
time it's as simple as that
the seven films we've seen in the saga
follow a formula and the ones we have
yet to see will perhaps follow it as
well but I do have one last point I'd
really like to talk over with you guys
it has to do with a phenomena that has
swept the movie community as of the past
few years put simply if a highly
anticipated film isn't received as a
work of utter perfection it's considered
a bad movie I've seen it happen with
tons of films over the past few years
most notably the Dark Knight Rises
and interstellar both of the
aforementioned films contain
storytelling problems and perhaps are
not the film we expected when we watch
the trailers but I simply can't refer to
them as bad movies because there's so
much good happening within them the
filmmaking on display in both of those
films is so strong that for me
personally it outweighs what flaws might
be present even though I recognize that
they're there buddy of mine dad Merle of
screen junkies Fame gave permission to
quote his tweet after he was accused of
disliking Jurassic world yet going easy
on the force awakens for those saying
I'm cutting the force awakens slack that
I didn't cut Jurassic world Jurassic
world is a bad movie with moments the
force awakens is a good movie with
problems for me there's just too much
good with in nearly every frame of force
awakens to discount it for its flaws
it's a terrific Star Wars movie and a
marvelously good time we finally have a
new Star Wars film with fantastic
characters excellent filmmaking and its
Sharman witty script guys I really truly
hope you enjoyed this analysis of now
just the force awakens but the Star Wars
saga in general and perhaps it helps
some to understand my viewpoint better
thank you so much as always for watching
my newest analyze review and I hope you
guys stay tuned for more and as always
if you like this you can click right
here and get stupid iced
you